foreign
apologize
wow
wow so pretty
oh my God
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
slow it down
so pretty holy crap I live for it
I love it
trash can we need that
foreign
[Music]
there's a ranger park next to me
I should probably put my national park
pass out I always forget that for some
reason
hopefully it's not coming over here
not yet
so I drove up here for Sunrise
um to Mount Rainier I Shot Sunrise
driving up the road and then stayed up
near the lodge for a little bit and now
I've come down to the lower lot because
there's better internet so I'm just
gonna edit and hang out until Sunset and
then I'll go shoot a little bit more
um and then my campsite's like 30
minutes from here there's a little bit
of wildfire smoke right now which isn't
ideal but it's not that bad
foreign
[Applause]
laughs
foreign
[Music]
this place looks a lot different now
gray grainy cold
the road through the mountains Beyond
this lake is closed probably buried in
snow
Here Comes Holly
[Music]
would you like some blueberries I would
oh
[Music]
time used to feel so infinite
I can do that
[Music]
the season seemed inevitable
summer was always just there waiting
right around the corner
and now scrubbing through all this
footage from months ago the passage of
time itself feels tangible
[Music]
I'll take it this is beautiful
this single Wildflower has come and gone
return to Earth
every blade of grass every drop of water
every sound of laughter
it'll never exist again exactly as it
was in this Frame
[Music]
this journey of learning how to film
edit and make sense of my experiences
out here on the road is one that has
been slowly unraveling my concept of
time
or maybe it's just that I'm getting
older
[Music]
hey
either way I find myself growing more
comfortable with the gravity of
impermanence
and the simple truth that
our time here is so very temporary
you and I
were Travelers
and we're only passing through
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
all I wanted was to stay in the
mountains and backpack until the snow
and cold weather pushed me out
but I wound up hurting my ankle pretty
bad on a hike I tried to tough it out
but it only seemed to get worse with
time
I could go see a doctor and get an
x-rayed but I highly doubt I mean I know
I don't know for sure but I I think I
just need to like rest and stay off of
it for a while but it's so hard to do
this time of year I'm just like
super bummed I finally get to use this
ace bandage that I've been carrying
around in my first aid kit since I moved
onto the road so that's cool I also have
these instant ice compresses well I only
bought two of them because
just a lot to throw away it's only like
a 10 to 20 minute application Max I feel
really bad having a bunch of these but I
got a couple so I'm gonna ice I'm gonna
wrap my foot and I've been trying my
best to elevate it when I sleep which
during the day is kind of hard because
it's supposed to be above your heart and
I'm like on the computer so my foot
would have to be like up here but but
yeah that's that's basically what I'm
working with
so that's why we're saying prices drop
so much so fast but longer term the
picture is a bit more complicated
whether it be a greater squeeze on the
rest of the global oil Market all of
this could potentially impact supplies
of increasing production
foreign
the entire Cascade Range seemed to be in
a haze
and there were no signs of relief
I wasn't ready to go but I kind of had
to leave
so I headed south
foreign
it would not be hard for me to finish
this whole thing and then have to pull
over and take a nap but I guess it's a
good thing I have my whole house with me
so I could do that
[Music]
foreign